um by the way ladies you're 26. Nat is
still somehow 21 five years later not
what welcome to the show Nat
thank you welcome Delhi over there Jamie
you're 27. I'm 28. 28. Emily how old do
I look
14. I actually get that a lot yeah you
look young but you're you're probably 20
you're 24. you're the baby of the bunch
that still hasn't uh revealed her age by
the way welcome to the show now thank
you look at that everyone see
okay uh starting with pearl what age
would you like to be married and what
age would you like your first kid
um
it's a good question I wish I was
married actually but I'd I'd like to do
that sooner rather than later so by what
age first kid like 28 29 okay so in the
next two three years you like to get
married have your first kid yeah facts
okay Natalia yes what Adrian what age
would you like to get married what age
would you like to have your first kid uh
I would like to get married in next
three years okay and then after getting
married I would like to have my first
kid after the first year of being
married got it yeah okay well
uh Jamie what age would you like to be
married by well you know my biological
clock is ticking Marissa told me so uh
sooner rather than later and I think
like a year to two years after we're
married because I would love to have a
year of like fun and traveling with my
husband before kids are involved
but you want to get married and have
your first kid you're like 32. okay so
in the next four years and then the kid
a year or two after that so you're
having your first kid at 30. oh I was
thinking 32 33 for a kid so I guess
we got to get married soon let's go
accepting applications on two girls one
blunt podcast yeah uh Emily who looks
fantastic by the way thank you uh what
age would you like to be married and
have your first kid
um I'd say I'd like to be married
in the next five years or so so like 29
around there so just giving myself a
little leeway so what I'm hearing from
all you ladies is ideally you'd like to
be married with kids give or take by age
30. yeah oh yeah ideally I
okay
um all right uh next question thank you
for being candid by the way
um
how necessary is a man in your life by
the age 30. by age 30 how necessary is a
man in your life let's do a one through
ten scale ten being like yo if I don't
have a man by age 30 like I I gotta
figure this thing out one being like I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm fine how necessary
is a man in your life by age 30 Pearl
um eight eight okay why isn't it a ten
well
because I feel like 35 would be like a
10. because I'm thinking like all right
if I was 30.
like I feel like there has to be worse
which would be 35 or 40. you know so you
have to okay seven you know I'll do
seven eight thirty five 9 40 10 50.
that's just math right there ladies
what I'm just saying you gotta like
because in my head I'm like you have to
have one you're done yeah you have to
have one that's worse I know okay I know
10 is the worst you said eight by Thirty
average out the skin
yeah and then 10 by 40. yeah I think
that's what you meant yeah right yeah
okay not
um how necessary is a man in your life
by age 30. by age 30 I would say
I would say eight as well okay eight as
well now by age 35
uh I would say 10. Okay 40.
um I'm already I reached 10.
the wonderful Jamie by age 30 how
necessary is a man in your life one
through ten
what do you mean by necessary like
like to have children how about this by
age 40
how necessary is a man in your life
I'm gonna say 10. yeah
fair enough uh
Emily by age 30 how necessary is a man
in your life keep in mind you're only
24. yes I'm
I don't want to be like my parents and
have my kids at age 40. okay so
newsflash gentlemen out there women have
this 30 age 30 barometer where it's like
the biological clock is ticking that
does not exist for men like I encourage
men wholeheartedly brah hold out until
you're at least 30. hold out
work on yourself work on your passion
work on your business keep improving
keep striving and then you'll be very
much high in demand low in Supply by the
time you're 35 as an example okay
uh shifting gears here what do you think
of a single 40 year old man who has his
quote unquote [ __ ] together what's his
number call me
just whatever you define as [ __ ]
together his [ __ ] is together
financially sexually romantically
socially lifestyle his [ __ ] is together
what's his phone number boom gotcha it
starts with 305.
uh go ahead what do you think of that
type of man 40 year old man who has his
[ __ ] together single no sometimes I
wonder when a man is 40 like I think a
lot of girls in our conversation when we
see like an older dude hanging out with
a bunch of us and they're 40 and we're
like what's wrong with them again
something's wrong with you as a 40 year
old man what's wrong with me failed
relationships maybe inability to love
and actually commit and you're in Miami
and you have a Playboy lifestyle
spot on I don't need to go see that
psychiatrist anymore at least you're
accountable about it but but so you know
for me as a woman I'm gonna see that and
I'm like he's not ready to set up it
comes off is not ready to settle and I
feel like you maybe doing that for a
while like so I'll give you I'll give
you a little twist maybe that guy is the
most ready to settle maybe because he's
been around the block he's driven all
the cars he's made all the money are we
talking about exceptions Adam oh well
exceptions are made for exceptions
exceptions are made for exceptional men
okay so for the most part we have a that
40 year old guy with the [ __ ] together I
have a question would you prefer a 40
year old guy that's been like both have
no kids but one's been divorced which
would you pick
interesting question wait say that again
because to me if he's been divorced that
means he's like more willing to commit
than the guidance yeah yeah I'm curious
if you guys have the same thought
process it would be why were they
divorced so like why because it didn't
work out let's just hello because of him
that's fine no which one would you
prefer yeah prefer you pick one and it
was semi-mutual never been married at 40
or divorced at 40. who would you prefer
prefer that is maybe maybe divorce
because they have that experience so you
want someone who's failed in their
marriage rather than someone who hasn't
gotten married
I think I would pick somebody who's not
been divorced if I could pick
um yeah I think that's fair to say like
a 40 year old man if I'm going after 40
year old men I I kind of have an
expectation that they may be divorced
well because I just kind of I've been
engaged I've been engaged I kind of
gauge like because I feel like when
you're getting to know a guy you kind of
are gauging how willing he is to commit
yeah and to me it's like if I hear he's
been divorced I'm like oh he's more
likely to do that again unless there's
like a oh brutal divorce or something
like a Serial divorce there yeah
sometimes when people come like divorced
they come with certain baggage and that
also affects how they commit to you so
that's also something to consider
because like I've dated somebody who has
been divorced and that affected like
certain ways that we dated and certain
things that he did so I would rather
have someone who's possibly not been
divorced so that we can experience like
first time things together that would be
kind of my I think all women want to be
the chosen one right right but it's not
shocking if a man is divorced like if I
meet a guy who's 40 and he's single but
he has kids to me I'm like all right at
least a woman wanted to have kids with
you you know so that's true there's pros
and cons to it but if you ask me do I
pick I'm like I'd rather you not be
divorced and like we can do it together
next question we just talked about the
ideal age you want to get married kids
right the guys are listening the girls
are answering this is great we just
talked about a 40 year old man who has
his [ __ ] together for the most part it
was call me I respect that Pearl
um now flipping it on you what do you
think of the 40 year old woman who's
single has her [ __ ] together what do you
think about that woman and what would
you think if you were in that position
Pearl you go first I mean she's done
it's over I mean
what can you really offer to a guy after
40. men get married because they want to
have kids at that point like you should
just try to find a guy for companionship
and maybe take marriage off the table
because why on Earth would he marry you
at 40 what can you offer okay what are
your thoughts Jamie
woman who's 40 single and has her [ __ ]
together
I think that a lot of women are like can
be happy with that would I want that no
not I wouldn't want that personally but
if that were me like I'm gonna make the
best I like how you said I would adopt I
like how you said can be happy instead
of are happy
yeah I would say because there's because
some that aren't there are some people
who are single they did the boss babe
thing they're 40 years old and then
they're like I want to get married and
have kids somehow and they're like you
have to be real as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible